[Music]
I mean there are people who are trying
to promote brain surgery for addiction
using electrical stimulation of that
area and it doesn't work any better than
methadone um and that's not to say that
methadone isn't the most useful drug we
currently have but it does not involve
invasive surgery and I should say
methadone and buprenorphine the Oakley
ID agonists are the best treatments that
we have for opioid addiction and what
they do is two things the first thing is
they cut the death rate by 50% which
this happens whether you continue using
on top or not so that's like sheer harm
reduction and that's wonderful if we can
keep you alive long enough that you
stabilize your life that is a lot better
than having you die the other thing that
they do is they allow people who are
ready to stabilize their lives so you
couldn't tell right now if I was on a
maintenance treatment or not because
basically once you get a tolerance to
these drugs you are not high or impaired
and you can drive and you can work and
you can love and you can do all of these
things what we don't understand this we
think oh you've just substituted one
addiction for another no what you've
done is you've substituted compulsive
behavior despite negative consequences
and now you just have physical
dependence and that's not a real problem
as long as you have a safe and legal
supply I think the most important place
to start is that addiction is a learning
disorder it's not a sign that you are a
bad person and if you want to have a
safe and addiction free or at least
lower level addiction workplace or
school you want people to feel included
and comfortable and safe and you don't
want this to be an adversarial thing the
research shows that the best way to get
people help is through compassion and
empathy and support and absolutely not
tough love there may be situations in
which an employer has to fire somebody
because they're four four
just degraded so much that's there's no
other option but they shouldn't think
I'm doing them a favor by firing them
because that will make them hit bottom
and it will help them sometimes that
happens but sometimes they just go on to
a life of homelessness and then die so
you can't assume that creating extra
negative consequences is actually going
to help a person with addiction what you
want to do is is ally yourself with them
and presuming this as an employee that
you want to keep how you know help them
realize that this is not a sin I am NOT
trying to control you what I want to do
is for you to be at your best at work at
home and you're not being at your best
right now so what can we do to help well
I think the important way to start that
conversation is to first not assume that
a problem that you think might be drugs
is drugs the person could be having any
number of mental illness any number of
mental illnesses the person could be
having you know there's a million things
that could look like oh you think they
have a drug problem and there's
something else going on so if you
approach the person with respect and not
assuming that you're going to find a
drug thing unless you know I mean
obviously in some situations it's
completely obvious but in most
situations it isn't and so the best way
I think is to say I've noticed XYZ I'm
worried about you I'm concerned about
you I want you know to make sure that I
can help you so if it comes from a place
of not like I caught you you know you
know because there's so much advice that
is just like you know will threaten to
fire them if they don't change and drug
test them immediately and all of this
kind of stuff which destroys trust you
know so that's not to say that if
somebody is doing something dangerous or
clearly you know inappropriate that that
behavior doesn't need to be addressed
but it is to say that you can approach
somebody in a confrontational degrading
and sort of high-powered manner or you
can approach them as an equal human
being deserving of respect and if you do
the latter you will have much better
results well and I have to say it's
almost never going to be easy because
people on whether they have addiction or
mental illness or anything else going on
with them often don't want to admit to
themselves that there's a problem and
you know in the addictions field there's
have been this whole thing we got a
breakthrough denial and everything like
that well people have denial for good
reasons if we didn't have denial
everybody would be sitting around
obsessing about death or at least I
would be you know it's it's a defense
mechanism because we need defending so
recognizing that can allow you to
approach somebody not from an attacking
stance approach somebody from a
befriending sort of stance and that is
hard to do and some people are going to
get very defensive no matter what you do
and it's not going to be a pleasant
conversation most of the time but you
can make you can minimize harm I mean
the this whole thing always comes down
to like reducing harm making things less
unpleasant if you can't make them non
unpleasant or actually Pleasant you know
the so it's it's really but the main
thing is like see them as a full human
being and I think really important in
getting people into any kind of
treatment is that I and I always say
this to parents or anybody who has an
addicted loved one the first step should
always be a complete thorough
psychiatric evaluation by somebody who
is not affiliated with any treatment
organization so that you can know going
in
what the problems may be and what kind
of services you should be seeking you
know there are some absolutely wonderful
treatment providers who if somebody
shows up who is not appropriate for
their services they will send them away
there are also unfortunately many people
who will just take that person to make
profit off of them and they will not
help that person and they will not
inform them that for example if they
stayed on maintenance they would have a
50% reduction in their death risk they
would just say we do absence that's good
for you blah you know um and so I think
you know again this is a sort of buyer
beware industry in the rest of Medicine
it's pretty easy to say okay here's
PubMed this is the treatment for this
particular cancer that you know has the
most evidence behind it and here's the
guy who designed the best treatment
let's go find this person in addiction
it's like all virtually all based on
like reputation and advertising and it
is you know it is very difficult to
actually find programs that provide
evidence-based care this is also a
problem in mental health more generally
but anyway the the point here is is that
in order to get care that is good for
you you need to advocate for yourself
and if you have an employer that's
willing to advocate for you that's even
better the way I think that employers
could do an enormous amount of good by
demanding that the treatment providers
they work with the treatment that they
cover is evidence-based and is not
restricted because of money but is
restricted because stuff that doesn't
work shouldn't be paid for
[Music]